[Música]
es hora de hablar de salud en France 24
y por ello me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañera Omar Romero sala mar
bienvenida Buenos días
empezamos en Estados Unidos porque hay
un nuevo estudio que vincula la
inflación y la nutrición si por supuesto
es un estudio que lo ha hecho el grupo
Cleveland Clinic en Estados Unidos y
básicamente Recuerda que el alza de los
precios en general también repercute en
un alza el precio de la comida de los
alimentos haciendo que la comida sana la
comida fresca sea todavía más cara que
la comida rápida o la Ultra procesada en
general y además con especial énfasis en
la población en este caso hispana en la
población Latina de media vemos según
este estudio de este grupo que en
Estados Unidos el 45% de las personas
más o menos comen comida rápida una vez
a la semana y el porcentaje crece al 51%
cuando se trata de población hispana
mientras que por el contrario un 70% de
media más o menos tiene se prepara
comida en su casa Unas cuatro veces por
semana Y ese porcentaje disminuye al 63%
cuando se trata de la población hispana
esto al final en que se traduce Pues que
esta población hispana está comiendo más
fuera está comiendo más ultraprocesados
y está comiendo menos alimentos frescos
en su dieta y además el 60% de ellos
según este estudio también recuerda que
su principal Barrera para no comer de
forma sana o alimentos frescos es
precisamente el dinero el costo que
tienen estos alimentos Marc podríamos
encontrar muchas causas pero usted
explíquenos Por qué los alimentos
ultraprocesados son más baratos claro
vamos a empezar porque es un
ultraprocesado y ahí están todas estas
respuestas no al final son estos
alimentos que pasan por procesos
industriales complejos que tienen unas
preparaciones a partir de sustancias que
ya son derivadas de otros alimentos
alimentos y que suelen incluir
conservantes edulcorantes a también
colorantes no con el objetivo sobre todo
de que puedan tener una vida más larga
que puedan estar almacenados durante
mucho tiempo estamos hablando por
ejemplo de carnes procesadas como las
salchichas las hamburguesas las barras
de cereales las sopas instantáneas toda
la comida que esté lista para
precalentar y para comer como por
ejemplo las pizzas son muchos pero
básicamente dicen eso que si un producto
contiene más de cinco ingredientes
probablemente sea un producto Ultra
procesada Y qué pasa ahí pues que
precisamente a las materias primas que
usan son muy baratas producirlos a gran
escala es muy barato cuesta muy poco
están disponibles 24 horas al día no en
cualquier parte duran mucho tiempo
almacenados son altamente rentables Y
como dice aquí en este artículo que
estaba publicado en septiembre de 2022
en The conversation lo que pasa También
es que suelen ir acompañados de una
publicidad y unas técnicas de marketing
cada vez más sofisticadas y cada vez más
agresivas haciendo que estos alimentos
no solo sean accesibles sino que también
sean muy atractivos para todos bueno Y
también un poco
gustosos digamos
eso no lo podemos negar nos gustan estar
muy buenos que vamos están muy buenos
bueno Cuáles Pero entonces Cuáles son
las consecuencias de los ultraprocesados
sobre la salud bueno a ver Son son
muchas los alimentos ultraprocesados
desgraciadamente por lo menos que están
son ricos en azúcar en sal en grasas no
saludables y al contrario tienen muy
poca proteína o tienen muy poca fibra no
por ejemplo Entonces por ejemplo por
este aumento por esta gran cantidad de
azúcares que tienen pueden entrañar más
riesgo de diabetes también hay algunos
estudios que lo relacionan con un mayor
riesgo de cáncer de colon aunque esta
causa efecto todavía no está totalmente
probada y esclarecida Pero sí hay este
vínculo también por supuesto provocan un
desbalance en la microbiota intestinal
que sabemos cada vez más que tiene
muchos impactos en todos los aspectos de
nuestra salud desde salud digestiva pero
también incluso la Salud Mental hay
muchas hay muchos estudios ya que
relacionan esa microbiota intestinal con
dificultades o más enfermedades de Salud
Mental y además pasa algo y es que
sacian mucho menos por lo tanto
necesitamos comer muchos más alimentos
de estos ultraprocesados para sentirnos
igual desafiados para sentirnos igual de
llenos Entonces esto también nos hace
entrar también en un bucle digamos de
tener que comer cada vez más para
sentirnos igual de llenos y hay un
último impacto también que es el de la
salud cardiovascular hay un estudio del
2019 de la Universidad de París que
básicamente concluye que entre las
personas que tenían un consumo más alto
de Ultra procesados hubo 277 accidentes
cardiovasculares es decir es relativos
al corazón y a la circulación sanguínea
por cada 100.000 personas cada año esa
cifra había bajado a 242 en las personas
que casi no consumían este tipo de
alimentos entonces vemos que pues por
supuesto hay un amplio abanico de
consecuencias sobre la salud de comer en
exceso este tipo de alimentos Bueno
podemos decir que de alguna manera Se
podrían comer con moderación con
bastante moderación claro para mí al
final lo importante es que lo que lo
saquemos un poco de lo individual no
porque todos tenemos al final mucha
culpa del día que nos comemos las
galletas o La Barrita de cereales no y
no nos damos cuenta de que al final no
tiene tanto que ver quizás con las
decisiones individuales de cada uno
Obviamente todos nos podemos esforzar en
cocinar más en casa en comer menos fuera
en comer mejor en hacer varias cosas en
este sentido Pero es cierto que al final
y lo vemos con esto de la inflación y
volviendo como estábamos Empezando este
espacio no las personas también sus
capacidades económicas deciden Cómo
pueden cocinar y por ejemplo se
recomiendan políticas públicas que hagan
eso que las comidas sanas sean igual de
atractivas e igual de baratas que al
final un paquete de patatas fritas no
por ejemplo entonces bueno sacar un
poquito eso Y sacarnos de esa culpa
también propia para entender que es un
problema social colectivo que tiene que
tener también Al final soluciones
políticas no hay que hacer que la comida
fresca sea más barata que la otra
procesada hacer que la comida fresca
pero que igual los productores también
puedan tener una rentabilidad de esta
comida fresca Claro sin que sin que
tenga Consecuencias negativas al final
sobre estas personas así es Mara usted
muchas gracias por toda esta información
Gracias Valentina